cool and then I can't hear anymore hey
Biden you just do whatever you want
without listening to it hearing anybody
[Music]
all right and absolutely random and
probably not necessary news for anybody
to ever hear or care about
check this out
I was on I-95 southbound from
Jacksonville all the way to St Augustine
are finding a mysterious yellow line
running down the middle of the
interstate
that's a hell of confusing now today we
sent news for Jacks reporter Jim Piggott
in our mobile Newsroom to find out where
it came from and yeah are they just
using uh just a line that's going
straight or is it a cross it just is a
[__] long yellow line for 20 miles
and sometimes it just it's like somebody
just decided to paint a yellow line for
20 miles and they just realized it
existed now it was it just showed up
like late last Friday
but it's throwing hella people off
because people don't know what the right
rule to follow is yeah because you know
when you're dangerous wait you just
you're just in automatic autopilot of
like following traffic rules and signals
when you see a dotted line when you see
a solid line when you see a yellow line
when you see an arrow you just
understand something about that but when
a random ass yellow Line's there
everybody's [__] up did someone just
like open the back trunk and then they
spray painted the ground that's what I
was thinking or like yeah like RV no
open a door that goes under
yeah how's it so straight yeah that
looks professionally yeah it looks like
a com like the company that actually
does those usually doesn't happen pretty
slowly though it's not like a fast it's
not like you're you're going 65 miles
yeah they're walking it seems yeah yeah
so they planned it during traffic jam so
then they can do that slowly that would
be the [__] funniest senior prank
type like prank ever though for 20 miles
20 miles 20 miles somebody must have
been high did the job wrong
or something so my um the funniest thing
on my name my neighbor on the cul-de-sac
right
he was annoyed of how many people would
park on his like thing because he can't
take the trash out so he just painted
that [__] all red
yeah
just by himself like and then people
stopped following it nice yeah what if
he parks there and he gets a ticket
that'll be hilarious so he's not even a
real one goddamn and I painted myself
yeah I do see those fools in La that'll
like come out and like you know they own
that orange cone yeah and they're just
putting it there I hate those Foods man
right take that [__] seriously bro Cato
that's just a racket though in K-Town
you know what I mean it's like every
parking lot it's like at a certain time
it's now just valet yeah yeah and no
matter what and that like as soon as it
hits five o'clock
everywhere he goes like this
everywhere you go you see the families
where they they they hold the parking
they save it you guys see those yeah you
can park two cars but the guy go in the
middle Oh yeah and when the family comes
they're like bro what
kind of the system dude you got another
10 families in one apartment Jesus
everybody got a Hustle
especially for parking bro get a bigger
place people get shot over parking you
know I almost fought a dude over a
parking you should I think I think
that's reasonable yeah why did you
almost fight a dude because it was like
late at night and some dude is just
waiting at the
the side of the parking just waiting for
his friend and I'm like yo get the [__]
out just get out I want to park right
there and that's it and he's just like
no way man no way
and he just kept waiting there sitting
down and I was just like yo get the [__]
out of there so I try to park and you
start screaming and I was just like
you know what
I'm gonna just let this one go yeah I
was eating I was even trying to you know
what I mean but
no you should go back to that area and
paint the curb bread
and call the cops look at the end of the
day it's Kate's house I'm in L.A I don't
know yeah
well you're not in K-Town
no I'm in West Hollywood we have to oh
that area has more parking you have to
have but there's like yeah West Hall or
Hollywood it's like 50 signs on the pole
yeah there's no parking from four to
seven seven to three and then on the
weekends Sunday okay Street sleeping on
Monday dude that [__] is like you have
to be like a competent college graduate
to understand how to Parkinson or
reading comprehension through the roof
dude you know what I'm saying come on
don't you got a city permit for people
that can park there too yeah we have we
have the guest one and uh residence
awesome so our strong I didn't know that
they do this for Pasadena right so I
parked in front of my own house and got
a ticket oh but you live in a nice area
bro oh cause you need like an overnight
pass or something in front of my own
house
I can't use my own curb on my own house
and they're like you need to have an
overnight parking and I was like if you
could prove that you live here then
we'll wave it and I'm like oh okay so
you go down to see the hall and then you
do it but I had no idea and then from
that point on could you park there you
still have to get overnight passes well
I was just being lazy because I have a
driveway and a garage and I just didn't
park in it I just parked on the street
and walked inside oh man but yeah if you
get a permit you can use that and park
on the street do you pay for your pass
oh yeah it's 80 a year it's 80 years
who here has probably gotten the most
parking tickets of all time not me It's
gotta be between me and Bart I don't
know I've gotten a good amount I think
I've got a good amount but I don't think
it's a lot I would say when I went to
UCLA I got a [__] ton
because they had a [__] ton over there
and I got my car towed a couple times
like like there was one time like
um
in you know in apartments because they
know parking's so scarce and people try
to get an apartment close to campus
uh just for the parking like you don't
just get the room if you want parking up
to pay additional yeah and then
um
one time I was like oh you know what
like I my parking is actually between
two pillars
so I think I had a friend stay over and
I just had them stay in my parking space
and I'll just park in between the two
pillars which isn't blocking anything
for just like overnight and then I
remember waking up in the morning and my
car was towed I'm like [__]
that's like 300 bucks as a honestly you
don't have money you know and then UCLA
has all the stupid la like this side
Friday this side Thursday but then if
the other if it's [__] Ash Wednesday
then you gotta do whatever you're like
God [__] damn
too happy Wednesday
okay tell if you park on the if you park
in the wrong Plaza
for that restaurant whatever someone's
watching you the whole time how do they
even do that they have parking
attendants don't they I don't know but
[__] yellow house no but when
we went to Trade Tech the one in South
Central I parked at the McDonald's on my
class only an hour I'm good I come out
car's gone [__] yeah dude towed it
how many times you got your car towed
quite a bit
by that time we're supposed to go
golfing yeah with JK and I had to leave
because Tiff got oh yeah yeah she parked
we can't park on our street from four to
six and it was a Friday and I realized
since I've been walking my dogs whenever
people park at four to six on a Friday
that's the only time they tow because
they get you on the weekend so then you
have to pay when you pick up the car on
Monday it's double time yeah
exactly exactly so throughout the middle
of the week they just give people
tickets but when it's on Friday they
[__] you over hard so Tiff went out
because the FedEx guy was blocking our
driveway so she's like [__] it I have to
be in a meeting she parked in the car on
the street she forgot came back out to
go golfing with us and she was like my
car's gone and that [__] was like 600
bucks oh my God bro that [__] hurt that
[__] bro and every time I see the
parking people I want to be like [__]
you get a real job it's crazy even just
parking tickets are 75 bucks 85 bucks
like it is ridiculous and you can't take
your motorcycles though really nope
can't just pick it up and take it away
well I don't know about that part but
they can't take it they can't take it
what do you mean they can't take it do
you know all the spots all the streets
that needs the the permit bikes don't
they counted as like a bicycle or
something I don't know but they just
can't ticket it because I got two
tickets for a minute and I called them
they said oh sorry
oh I don't know why I have no idea why
motorcycles don't need permit a
residence or anything like that
dude motorcycle seems like the hacking
and you guys could do carpool we could
do carpool we could play Lanes we could
park in front of store
should we all be in Vietnam and just be
on two wheels it's just more dangerous
out here yeah just because no one knows
who the [__] you just gotta have a loud
ass motorcycle and people can be like
what the [__] where's that sound coming
from and they're gonna slow down they're
gonna think I'm an attention-seeking
loser that's fine as long as you get to
your place on time but then what about
my eardrums when I'm older because I had
such a loud motorcycle and then I can't
hear anymore hey but then you just do
whatever you want without listening to
it hearing anybody
that's a good point [__] because [__]
be hearing too much yeah yeah [__]
listening ain't listening too much right
and you're just like huh [__] people
yeah gunshots siren
no carriages I don't know I'm playing my
games
seven years old
fire that's the life bro I know I am at
70. I'm playing games you're still gonna
be biking at 70. [__] yeah I'm gonna get
a freaking crazier Harley bike
[Music]
foreign